et bien ce mardi restera comme une bien
mauvaise journée pour les dames à cannes
imaginez plutôt c'est d'abord christophe
lambert qui se fait draguer par un porte
clé dans le film de marco ferreri a beau
c'est dommage pour un beau gars comme ça
non et puis ce n'est pas tout après ses
ailières charlotte rampling qui elle se
découvre des penchants pour les singes
enfin pour un stage en particulier dans
le film français du cinéaste japonais
oshima on se demande vraiment ce qu'ils
ont tous avec ses animaux
c'est ici oui c'est une question à
laquelle vous ne répondez pas dans le
film mais je vous demande d'y répondre
personnellement vous avez misé sur la
question savoir si peut-être plus
excitant de faire l'amour avec un
chimpanzé qu'avec un homme c'est à vous
des idées
ah bah moi je les avais essayé va
essayer si vous allez voir
max mon amour c'est un film qui fait
parler vous l'avez compris et même
répondre à l'occasion comme ce matin par
exemple lors de la conférence de presse
de charles autres en tout cas qui se
veut une fable sur l'attrait et sur les
dangers de la marginalité un porte clés
qui racolent un chimpanzé qui drague on
trouve de tout au festival de cannes
dans l'ordre et dans le désordre mrinal
sen l'un des très grands du cinéma
indien est lui aussi venu au festival
dans ses valises il apporte genesis qui
figure à la sélection officielle
une autre fable mais sur le monde des
pauvres
alors pour lui qu y at il de commun
entre 100 films et les 3
que ce soit un chimpanzé vous que ce
soit au portugal et en fait quoi que ce
soit il faut voir le film pour apporter
un commentaire
si vous voulez connaître
il va toujours aux histoires qui parlent
et des rapports ou montre des hommes des
histoires qu'on ne sait jamais cette
histoire d'amour par exemple entre une
femme mariée pas être en reste
le message du réalisateur bague ali qui
pensent que le monde sera toujours à
refaire et qui lui a consacré 25 films
la vision d'une ville qui s'installe
dans l'été tandis que tourner les
projecteurs
le festival de cannes c'est aussi ce
mélange insolite alors pourquoi ne pas
suivre l'exemple